it discusses peace and it pushes out
there this concept that they keep
rejecting peace so I'm going to play two
clips back to back because it seemed
like these talking points are put out
there by the same individuals often I'll
have you address that you're the one who
made up pal the Palestinian the
Palestinians the Palestinians were
offered a state in 1936 in the appeal
commission they rejected it they were
offered to state in 1947 the UN
partition plan they rejected it they
were offered to state 1967 after Israel
conquered Judean Samar in the West Bank
they rejected it they were offered a
state in 2000 yasar Barack they rejected
it they were offered a state with aod om
2008 they rejected it they have Israel
unilaterally withdrew from Gaza in 2005
and they did not create a state claim is
that the Arabs did not reject peace and
then in your own disquisition you
admitted that the Arabs rejected the
peel commission plan which was a
separation between the Jews and the
Arabs which gave an extraordinary amount
of land to the Arabs the Arabs then
rejected the peace partition plan
proposed by the United Nations in 1947
they then proceeded to reject the Oslo
Accords in '93 after that they rejected
the Y River Accords in '98 they rejected
AUD barack's very generous offer in 2000
I think they're kind of the same talking
points of you is this anything new that
you've heard are you familiar with both
of these uh figures here Ben Shapiro and
the um the another follower of the um
Theodor Herzel familiar with
him um
impossible to dis tangle all the
nonsense that's being said there so I'll
limit myself to some very basic facts
which the
record unimpeachably unimpeachably
demonstrates since beginning in the
early 1970s long long
long before Hamas even
existed the Palestine
leadership uh in the PLO it was called
the Palestine Liberation
Organization led by this fellow name
yaser Arafat and the Palestinians were
on record as supporting a two-state
settlement based on the June 1967 border
what has come to be called the
international
consensus two states on the June 1967
border and for the past 20 or so years
every year in the United Nations General
Assembly there is a resolution passed or
resolution put forth called peaceful
settlement of the Palestine
question and the terms of the settlement
are very
straightforward number one that Israel
has to withdraw from the territories it
occupied in June 1966 7 namely the West
Bank including East Jerusalem and
Gaza number two the settlements Israel
has built in the occupied Palestinian
territories now numbering about 700,000
or more Jewish settlers are illegal
under international law and those
settlements have to be
dismantled number
three there has to be what's called a
just resolution of the refugee question
based on the right of
return
and
uh number four the Palestinians should
be able to exercise the right of
self-determination in the territories
from which Israel withdraws those are
the terms of international law and those
are the terms embedded in that annual
resolution peaceful settlement of the
Palestine question every year the whole
world except the United States Israel
and some South Pacific
atos
Islands uh
tuvalu
Naru uh
Tonga aside from those Marshal Islands
aside from them the whole world votes in
one side Israel votes Israel the United
States vote on the other side that's the
record the whole world has been wanting
to try to resolve this problem on the
basis of international law and the basic
principles as applied of international
law as applied to the Israel Palestine
conflict and Israel and the US have
rejected it there are so
many silly stupid
uh
comments by those folks because they
don't know what they're talking about
they just get Israel talking points and
they have no clue what they're talking
about um so that to me is